[Music]
My name is Mike Seltzer.
I'm a principal researcher in
the speech and dialogue research
group at Microsoft.
And what we're showing here
today is Microsoft's custom
speech service.
This is part of cognitive
services, Microsoft's umbrella
of services that are available
in our mission to democratize AI
research and development.
So Microsoft has world-class
speech recognition.
Our algorithms and models are
clearly state of the art.
But for some developers who have
a different need or have a
particular application in mind,
they may be able to get better
performance by customizing the
models.
So this is very relevant if you
have an application with
particular jargon or vocabulary.
And it's also relevant if you
have an application deployed in
a particular environment, for
example, a noisy factory floor.
So what we allow the user to do
or the developer to do is to
bring their own data and
customize the models to their
application.
So the way we do that is with
this custom speech service.
You can log in, create an
account and upload your own
data.
So I'll give you a quick example
of a model we built here.
This is for an application --
we're pretending that this is a
kiosk in an airport and someone
would go up and want to get some
kind of flight information and
you can imagine that a terminal
of an airport is very, very
noisy and of course the
vocabulary is very specific to
traveling requests.
And so we've basically taken
those things and use that to
customize the model.
So, for example, if we give a
sample query here, you'll see
that the request was for
something that's showing please
show only class Q.
And so you can see, for example,
here that the baseline model,
because it was very noisy, it's
possible you weren't able to
hear it on the video, but it's a
very noisy utterance that the
baseline recognizer did a very
poor job, whereas the custom
recognizer did a very good job.
In fact, that allowed us to then
get the intent of the user very
accurately.
You can see here we were able to
figure out this was a flight
information request, where here
we were unable to figure out
what the intent of the user is
at all.
Now in addition to the various
ways developers can do this on
their own, we've also taken a
service and applied it to
PowerPoint in a way that enables
presenters to basically have
customized transcriptions for
all their slides.
So, for example, here is a
PowerPoint slide I took from the
Web involving organic chemistry.
And if I can start, and what we
do, we take all the material
that's on the slide, all the
text, and we use that, we take
all that text, update the
language model, the speech
recognizer.
In addition, we do an
intelligent crawl to go and
retrieve based on these words
other information from the Web
that can be used to inform the
model.
And so all that happens.
That goes seamlessly behind the
scenes to build an updated
custom endpoint that can do a
great transcription of your
materials.
So I'll do a quick example here.
Forgive me, I don't really know
anything about organic chemistry
although I'll try to speak about
it here.
So the slides will show up on
the screen.
As you see, it asks me:  Do I
want to customize the speech?
I say yes.
The other interesting thing
about the project is that all
these transcriptions can also be
transcribed into many languages
and you'll get this QR card and
people can log on on their
phones, tablets or devices in
the classroom and get the
transcriptions locally on the
devices in the same language or
translated into a number of
other languages.
So you can see, if I go here,
this is a lecture on
stereochemistry.
And I can come up to a slide
that has, for example,
interesting terminology like
hybridized carbons or plane of
symmetry, and you can see up
here we're getting these
transcriptions perfectly
accurate.
And this is a slide I like
because there's something here
called, in particular, mirror
image molecule, it's called
enantiomers, and I'm fairly sure
that thing is like enantiomers
and stereoisomers are not things
you'd find in the vocabulary of
a common speech recognizer but
here it's critically important
for transcribing your slides.
So as a result, we're able to do
a really good job.
So that's been a demonstration
of some of the things you can do
with the custom speech service.
Again, the PowerPoint
presentation translator is
available now for public
download, and the CRIS service
is also available for anyone to
go and give it a try.
So I hope you enjoyed that.